I'm lucky to have this car this is a
hand-me-down for my late grandmother
1989 Honda Accord with uh it's actually
not that bad 120,000 miles on it it's
kind of a company joke at this point
that I drive this car but you know
things running great right now so I'm
gonna stick with it I had worked in the
industry for eight years worked my way
up from the floor selling clothes at a
retail space and then I went and worked
in wholesale I was in New York City on a
sales trip and I just saw like how fast
things were going by me and at that
second it was just that second I just
was like I'm done done missing out it's
time to do my own thing then came the
tough part which was how do you actually
make clothes I didn't attend fashion
school it didn't study underneath
someone in Paris when you've never done
something before there's a learning
curve but I had a plan it's time to go
the way that I was going to be able to
really accomplish my dream was same way
that I had learned anything else by just
getting my hands dirty and kind of
figuring it out thank you I can remember
the first time I got a sample back with
a tag that said my own name and I was
hooked
no turning back I was just completely
hooked we're a basics company t-shirts
jeans and sweatshirts these are the
products that you wear 90% of your time
making those things well was kind of our
big idea in fashion 16-ounce French
terry custom did here in the United
States we put two zippers on the side
they go 9 inches up they conceal a
hidden kangaroo pocket I personally hate
wearing slim jeans with a low back rise
so I just set out to solve my own
problem the back rise is slightly higher
than the front this is what we call the
Escobar's sweatpants you were really one
of the first brands to introduce the
skin tight sweat pant at the ankles
recently we started to explore with mesh
we call this the rebel mesh sweatshirt
and we're lining it with super soft
cotton it's been highly sought after so
far we merge traditional craftsmanship
and traditional fabrics with a younger
aesthetic try and engineer everything
long and slim but it's also with great
eye for stitch details and fabric so
this is the one that we're using to do
we're custom making fabrics and that's
such a cool thing could you take it to
like a 6 on the loop join is not the
easiest person to work with no no we
said this as well he has this one idea
and we just go over and over and over
all right we do the samples we do the
samples it's a very tough process but
also it's very fun well that's we'll
just stick with this yeah have you
ordered it yet
from the time I was a child I've always
been very detail-oriented I'm probably a
perfectionist when I was eight years old
I was drawing cross-trainers riding
leathers and sending them off to Nike I
think what they said was we're only
working with patent-pending designs and
we really really appreciate you
submitting your design but like he
responded and that for me was enough
I've been obsessed with fashion style
and the culture behind it for as long as
I can remember this has been the only
thing that I've really ever cared about
I'll be honest with you I'm very
dyslexic school was never really like a
area where I shined air in my business
partner was my first tutor from like
sixth grade all the way through high
school and really got me through school
like it kind of became my best friend he
always took initiative from a young age
to kind of do things that were outside
the box
he kind of coached me in how to be cool
and what to wear and we would discuss
how we would one day start this business
and I know that seems kind of crazy but
it's the truth here we are now 10 15
years looking back we've been able to do
that when we first started out Aaron and
I invested our life savings it's about
two years of living off of nothing it
was sometimes skipping meals other times
it was literally eggs and oatmeal there
were a lot of points where it would've
been very easy for us to jump off the
ship and we chose not to it was for a
bigger vision and it was a choice and we
believed in what we were creating
getting the smallest taste of freedom
working on something for yourself that
you're deeply passionate about and have
been trying to create since you were a
child there's nothing like it